haha the Joe Rogan experience well I
think we're rapidly moving towards
opening up the country it's gonna happen
extremely fast over the next few weeks
so yeah so something I would be helpful
just add from an informational level is
when reporting sort of covert cases to
separate out diagnosed with covert
versus had covered like symptoms yes
because I've the list of symptoms that
could be covered at this point is like a
mile long so it's like the hard to sure
ill at all it's like II could be covered
so just just to give you a better
information
definitely diagnosed with covered or had
covered like symptoms
we're conflating those two so that one
that it looks bigger than it is then if
somebody dies is was covered a a primary
cause of the death or not I mean I mean
if somebody has cover gets eaten by a
shark we find their arm their arm has
covered it's gonna get recorded as a
cover death
is that real not basically not that bad
but heart attacks strokes get hit by a
bus cancer if you get hit by a bus could
go to the king of the hospital and die
and they find that you have covered you
won't be recorded as a covert death why
would they do that though well right now
that so you know the road is hell is the
road to hell is paved with good
intentions I mean it's mostly paved with
bad intentions but there is you know
some good intention of saving stones in
there too and the the the stimulus bill
that was intended to help with the
hospitals that were being over on with
with with code patients created an
incentive to record something as covert
that is difficult to say no to
especially if your hospitals going
bankrupt for lack of other patients
so the hospitals are in a bind right now
there's a bunch of hospitals or they're
following doctors as you were mentioning
they're you know they're transfer
half-full your it's hard hard to make
ends meet so now you've got like you
know I just checked this box I get
$8,000 mm-hmm
put on a ventilator for five minutes to
get $39,000 back or or I got a fire some
doctors so what's the what's in it now
this is a tough moral quandary is that
what you can do that's the situation we
have know what what's the way out of
this what do you think is like if if you
had the president's ear or if people
wanted to just listen to you openly what
do you think is the way out of this so
let's close clear up the data clear up
the data so like that I just so make
sure we recorded as Co but only if it is
somebody has been tested has received a
positive positive Kova test thought if
they simply have symptoms one of like a
hundred symptoms and then if if it is a
covert death it must be separate or was
this was covert a primary primary reason
for death or did they also have stage
three cancer or heart disease emphysema
and got hit by bus and had covered you
have read all this stuff about that
about them diagnosing people as a Cova
death despite other variables this is
not this is not a this is not a question
this is what is occurring and where are
you reading this from where are you
getting this from the public health
health officials have literally said
this is not this is not a question mark
right but this is never this is
unprecedented right like if someone had
the flu but also had a heart attack they
would assume that that person died of a
heart attack yes yeah so this is
unprecedented is this because this is
such a popular I don't use that word the
wrong way but that's what I mean a
popular subject and financial incentives
yes and like I said this is not some
sort of a moral indictment of sort of
hospital administrators it's just
they're in it they're they're in it in a
tough in a tough spot here they actually
don't have enough patients to pay
everyone if it took without following
furloughing doctors and and
firing staff and yeah this is a running
potentially going bankrupt so so they're
like okay well the similar spill says if
you know we get all this you know money
if we say if if they if it's a Cove of
death I'm like okay they coughed before
they died
in fact they're not even diagnosis code
but they simply if you had weakness a
cough shortness of breath but frankly
I'm not sure how you died without those
things yeah you yeah but there's so many
different things you could attribute to
Cove it - there's so many symptoms
there's diarrhea headaches dehydration
yeah cough yes but to be clear you you
you don't even need to have gotten a
covert Dyke Russ's you simply need to
have had one of many symptoms and then
have died for some reason and it's
covert so so then it makes the death
count look very high and then where it
were then stuck in a vine because it
looks like the death counts super high
and not going down like it should be and
now so then we should keep whatever you
know keep you know the shelter in place
stuff there and and keep people in their
home you know confine people the homes
so we need to break out of this this
we're stuck in a loop yeah and I think
the way to break out of this loop is to
have clarity of information clarity of
information will certainly help but
altering perceptions public perception
from people that are basically in a
panic there's a lot of essentially well
at least a month ago we're clearly in a
panic I mean right weird yet you know
when you look around April 5th April 6th
people were really freaking out but here
we are May and May people are relaxing a
little bit yes they're realizing ok I
actually know a couple of people that
got it it was just a cough and I know
some people that got it the word nothing
happened I know a lot of people who cut
it I know 0 people who died died I made
it bad no yeah a lot of people have got
it you
it's it's not what we feared we feared
something much worse that's correct
so the adjustments difficult to make so
you said first of all we need real data
you need it just just parse out the data
don't lump it all together no and then
if you give if you get people just parse
out the data better clearer clearer
information about like said was this an
actual curve a diagnosis or was it a did
they get the test and I can test came
back positiv or do they just have some
symptoms just parsed up those two out
and then parse out just if somebody died
did they die did they eat but that they
even have a coma test or did they just
have one of many symptoms like like look
how do you die without weakness I don't
know it's impossible basically yeah
you're gonna die you're gonna have
shortness of breath weakness and you
might kaufe little so so was it
quantified what was it yeah did that
person that did they actually have a
cover test and and the tests come back
positive and then if they died did they
die where we're covered was it isn't had
to be the the main course but it was a
significant contributor to their death
or was it not a significant contributor
to the death right it's not as simple as
just because you had Kovac Kovac killed
you it's definitely not right yeah yeah
I mean people die all the time they have
like flu and yes other colds and well we
don't say that they died of those flu
and other colds well that's what's so
weird I'm sorry it's so popular and I
use that word in a weird way but it's so
popular that we've kind of forgotten
people died pneumonia everyday yeah
people died of the flu didn't take a
break
Oh kovetz got this I'm gonna sit this
one out I'm gonna be on the bench I'm
gonna wait until kovetz done before I
jump back into the game of killing
people know the flus still here killing
people I mean every year in the world
several hundred thousand people die
directly of the flu yeah not not ten
gently right not every sixty one
thousand in this country last year yeah
I'm early five percent of the world
[Applause]